hey guys Pete here some big spoiler ish
news coming in from Belfast now that
Game of Thrones Season 7 filming is
officially underway
this is gonna be a short video to
discuss what we've heard is happening
some of this is just confirmation of
ideas that were already out there but
there is an interesting twist I hadn't
thought of so I'm gonna go over what's
out there in the Game of Thrones
preseason watch community and go over
some other rumors that you might have
heard of that have been debunked I'm
also doing a giveaway for subscribers so
make sure you stick around to the end
for details on that if you're a fan that
doesn't want to know about production
related spoilers then you will want to
stop watching now but feel free to check
out one of my other recent Game of
Thrones videos if you want to
participate in the giveaway all right so
if you don't follow any of the various
Game of Thrones information sites out
there it's still pretty hard to avoid
hearing bits and pieces of show related
news one such casting rumor that seemed
super unlikely when I first heard it was
that Angela Lansbury of Murder She Wrote
had signed on for Season seven this now
has been officially debunked as the
actresses team contacted Entertainment
Weekly to tell them the rumor wasn't
true another big story that got me all
excited last week turned that turned out
to not be true as well
on Reddit someone posted about a new
ISBN number being registered for the
winds of winter winds is George RR
Martin's sixth book in the song and Ice
and Fire series which has been highly
anticipated since the dance with dragon
came out wait like five years ago to
make this seem even more possible Amazon
France displayed a placeholder page with
a March release date for the book and
there was another sort of mysterious
entry about a book named jungfrau on
different sites and but in the end you
know Martin's publishers made statements
making clear the book was not done now
this doesn't mean the book won't be
available by that time but it does mean
that we are no less in the dark about
when it'll come out than we were before
and happier news Game of Thrones did
start filming season 7 and there has
been a flood of images from social media
of the actors arriving in Belfast to
shoot starting production also means
leaks about what's going on and those
are starting to surface pretty fast
about a week and a half ago we got info
that Daenerys would be visiting the
dragon pit and Kings Landing which I
went over in my dragon pit video so if
you haven't seen that you should check
out for that story today though Watchers
on the wall which is a trusted source
for Game of Thrones news published some
more juicy spoilers according to their
source shooting this week centered
around Yara and Theon Greyjoy engaging
in battle at sea the idea of a battle at
sea is something that we could have seen
coming after all season six ended with a
giant coalition of ships headed towards
Westeros but we are specifically hearing
about Theon and Yara out of all the
photos of actors that are surfacing I
still haven't seen any reports that
Emilia Clarke who plays Daenerys has
arrived to start shooting yet so this
could mean that the fleet has split up
the report goes on to say that uncle
Euron has been catching up to Yara and
Theon and that he takes one of them
prisoners during the battle that's the
thing that I thought was an interesting
twist this is pretty exciting but also
makes things hard to speculate on since
all of these characters have completely
different stories in the books
Yaron Theon are both prisoners at the
end of dance of dragons but they are way
up in the north we also have one sample
chapter from Theon's point of view from
winds of winter and we know that you're
on we know what Euron's up to from a
sample chapter from winds of winter as
well since those parts of their stories
aren't going to factor into the show I'm
left wondering if parts of them will be
grafted into how the show story has
developed I'll talk a little bit more
about that at the end but for now let's
look at what else the story was talking
about they confirm one thing that many
fans had theorized and I went over this
in my Queen Cersei video but they
basically said that you're on in Cersei
will be joining forces in season seven
they don't have any other details on how
the two will end up together but we can
see the obvious advantages they would
have since both lack popular support
outside of their own inner circles we
don't really know how much show you're
on will resemble book you're on but even
if he's a little watered down he would
still make a top-shelf bad guy according
to the report he also kills at least one
of the sand snakes so this all gives us
a lot to speculate about my initial
guess is that Euron will capture Theon
but it could really go either way I
guess it just depends on if his story
arc is the redemptive variety or if he
reflects a little bit more like where
he's at in the books if you're on had
Yara then that would set up Theon that
take charge and assert himself but on
the other hand if he grabs Theon than it
was
set up another yaar and Danny scene and
could strengthen their alliance through
a sense of purpose Tyrion has been seen
in Belfast so he may be travelling with
the Greyjoy's lanes and if you're on is
going to kill one of the sand snakes it
might as well mean that they're in this
battle of course Danny could be involved
but I think it makes more military sense
for her to split up her fleet plus if
she is there I'm inclined to think the
Dragons would make it hard for Euron to
walk away from the battle with his life
so my guess is that Danny will divide
her force and then you're on will attack
the other half led by the Greyjoy's I
think the Euron and Cersei alliance will
make for some interesting scenes and the
interview Dan and Dave did about a month
ago they talked about Cersei story as it
would develop over the season which led
me to believe that she wouldn't suffer
like a quick death not exactly sure how
Jaime will react to the alliance but at
the same time not really sure how he
will react to Cersei crowning herself
queen either there's a lot to think
about and I'm sure once we start getting
trailers way down the road things will
start getting a little clearer let me
know what you guys think in the comments
are you hyped about a Cersei you're on
axis of evil do you think you are will
get nabbed or do you think it'll be
Theon please like the video if you found
it enjoyable and don't forget to
subscribe when I hit 18,000 subscribers
I'm giving away a copy of a night of the
Seven Kingdoms all you have to do is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video once I hit the goal I'll pick one
subscriber and send the book their way
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon